literally false metaphorically true
again and just yeah there's just a lot
in this chapter in that book yet i i did
it's it makes me very i was doing it
while you're working on the tech stuff
yes so we actually
apparently
they have sold enough of them in advance
that the copies that we were supposed to
end up with got sent to other people so
anyway we have just seen it we're kind
of excited to just see it hold it in our
hands very much so so we're not going to
read on conformity or religion and
ritual or sex drugs and rock and roll
and the sacred versus the shamanistic
we're saving that for those of you who
actually get the book but we are going
to read literally false metaphorically
true
i am going to share that
here it's three pages
cultural beliefs are often literally
false but metaphorically true
consider farmers in highland guatemala
who have a long-standing tradition to
both plant and harvest crops only when
the moon is full
this they say allows the plants to grow
stronger and resist insect damage
what possible protective capacity could
the phase of the moon have on crop
health presumably none
but the phase of the moon can
synchronize the farmers
a full moon is effectively a giant sky
clock a keeper of time that everyone in
the region can see
if all farmers in the region believe
that a full moon has salutary effects on
their individual crops they will likely
restrict planting and harvesting to the
full moon and this will in fact benefit
everyone's crops just not for the reason
the farmers believe a belief in the
power of the moon to directly affect
crops effectively satiates predators by
concentrating the harvest into brief
periods during which time crop predators
cannot eat all of everyone's crops
it is easy to dismiss many myths and
beliefs of old precisely because they
are literally false
indeed doing so is almost a sport among
some hard-headed people
take astrology
it is clearly beyond reason to imagine
that the stars that we see many of which
are thousands of light years away are
having a direct impact on human behavior
similarly it is beyond reason to believe
that a passal of angry gods is the
reason for tsunamis yet among the moken
those who believe in those gods survive
at higher rates than those who don't
and it is surely beyond reason to
believe that a full moon is protective
of crop health yet among guatemalan
farmers precisely that belief results in
more productive farming
in each case the belief is literally
false but metaphorically true
this means that the cover story isn't
true but when people behave as if it
were they prosper
this is how religion and other belief
structures spread
even if such things are not literally
true acting as if they are benefits
people sometimes it even benefits the
biodiversity and sustainability of the
land in which they live
in its modern tabloid form astrology is
bunk
but astrology has probably not been so
everywhere and for all time
if and this is a big if you control for
where a person was born might not the
time of year that they were born have
effects on how they develop and
therefore who they become
and aren't astrological signs just an
ancient way of keeping track of the
months more or less
if we look at astrology this way rather
than as a modern indulgence that is too
free of context and history to have
meaning it begins to look promising
is a newborn in a minnesota winter
exposed to the same pathogens and
activities as a newborn in a minnesota
summer
surely not
and sure enough there has been work done
to bear out this idea
culling idea culling data from over 1.75
million records at new york presbyterian
columbia university medical center for
people born between 1900 and 2000
researchers found clear correlations
between birth month and lifetime disease
risk for more than 55 different
conditions with affected systems ranging
from cardiovascular to respiratory from
neurological to sensory the sheer number
and breadth of medical conditions that
vary in lifetime risk by birth month
should be enough to make a thoughtful
person rethink a wholesale rejection of
careful astrological thinking
for if there are demonstrable
differences in disease risk by birth
month why should we imagine that there
are no differences in personality
as an aside one prediction of this
approach to astrology is that if you
include both birthplace and date
astrology will have less power to
predict lifetime disease risk the closer
you get to the equator where seasonality
is much reduced from that in the
temperate zones
another prediction is that the more a
person moves around as a child the less
predictive astrology will be for them
and if you don't include birthplace
astrology should have no predictive
power at all
distortions that help you survive and
thrive are adaptive myths and taboos
often make little sense to outsiders and
some of them are surely misguided even
counterproductive for those who honor
them
some surprisingly precise taboos are
likely over generalizations from an
actual event
among the kameyra of the brazilian
amazon the eating of scaleless fish is
forbidden for both pregnant women and
their husbands
it may well be that long ago a terrible
fate befell a woman her unborn child or
her entire family after eating a fish
without scales and that the fish was the
only explanation that stuck
similarly on the oat plateau of
madagascar in the village of mahatsunjo
there is a taboo against eating hammer
cops a close relative of pelicans
this taboo is directly tied to villagers
having seen one fly over just as a man
died
elsewhere in madagascar it is taboo for
young men to eat mutton before wooing
taboo for pregnant women to eat the meat
of hedgehogs or to walk through fields
of pumpkin taboo for a son to build his
home to the north or east of his
father's house to our western
sensibilities this seems like
superstition pure and simple
the word for taboo in malagasy fadi has
a complex meaning as well in batsma
sarica the language of the people of
northeastern madagascar fadi means both
taboo and sacred
that which is fadi is mandated by the
ancestors be it mandated that you don't
do it or that you do
despite the preceding examples many
believe smiths and taboos are literally
false metaphorically true malagasy fadis
come cloaked in the language of gods and
ancestors but it is still easy to see
the wisdom in many of them if you simply
look at the prohibition do not build a
house over or against a new landslide do
not step on a dead dog as you might get
hydrophobia rabies do not divorce your
wife while she is pregnant
good advice
we predict that those taboos that have
lasted the longest are most likely to be
hiding an important cultural truth in
plain sight beware chesterton's fatties
the old ideas i'm sorry beware
chesterton's bodies the old ideas may
have hidden truths and those truths may
be difficult to recover once they have
been dismissed
joseph campbell observed that mythology
is a function of biology he was correct
as an evolved creature you are built to
succeed and sometimes that involves
telling yourself stories
finding yourself in a raft near the top
of a dangerously tall waterfall you
might be about to die
if you believe that the shore is within
reach and paddle like hell you just
might make it
those deflated by long odds will leave
no trace
belief can be the difference between
life and death
i believe you have all uh you have
angered both the old gods and the new
with that
yes i'm sure that will um anger at least
some proponents of both the old gods and
the new
um
but i mean it
precisely because as is true of
everything in the book
we are trying to weave our way carefully
um down a road
that understands the reality and
importance of history and reveals a path
forward or at least the beginning of a
path forward that has uh
that has the potential to reveal great
things which we can't even yet imagine
yep i mean in fact you know
as we present this in the book and as we
have mentioned periodically here
this activity whether it's writing the
book and having people read it and
discuss it or us talking about ideas
from it and other things
is effectively a modern version of the
campfire around which
consciousness would have been practiced
and i think maybe we did not say up
front
that one of the implications of the
model of consciousness and culture that
we present
is that it reverses the natural
expectation about why consciousness
emerged so while consciousness has been
famously resistant to explanation if you
think of it primarily
as and we argue that it would initially
have evolved as a mechanism for
individuals to pool their cognitive
strengths and come up with
an emergent sum that is greater than
or an emergent hole that is greater than
the sum of the parts
then individual consciousness which we
all take to be primary because we
experience individual consciousness and
inter-subjective consciousness is
something that we only have in direct
access to the idea that we may share a
thought
is not as vivid as any thought that
either of us would have it's much more
powerful because there are two minds
involved in creating it but it is much
less visceral and so
our argument is that we have studied
consciousness incorrectly in science and
in fact this is reinforced just by the
practicality you can put an individual
into an fmri machine you cannot put a
group of people into an fmri machine and
see what is
shared in their cognition at least not
simply one of the big drum beats of the
book of course is a rejection a
recognition of the value of the
reductionism in modern science and
medicine and also a rejection of its
ubiquity of mistaking that which can be
easily measured for
that which is the most important thing
in a system absolutely and so in in in
this case it's not that we deny the
existence and the importance of
individual consciousness but we argue
that it is likely to have come second
that you build a model that allows
people to pull their consciousness
together and then once you have the tool
that involves knowing what is likely in
someone else's mind maybe because you
placed it there you now have a tool in
which you can have an argument with
yourself you can hold two ideas and
compare them as if you were two
different minds comparing notes
and in any case uh we regard this as
likely a solution to many of the most
difficult issues surrounding
consciousness just simply by getting the
evolutionary order of operations correct
[Music]
you